hallo
ich willkommen in meiner toten wird
heute möchte ich wieder ein video in
meiner kategorie nachgemacht original
trifft zelle machen und zwar werde ich
heute nutella selbst machen und wehrt
euch zeigen wie ihr das auch ganz
einfach selbst nachmachen können
ich werde mein video heute also dieses
rezept wieder mit einem thema verbinden
und zwar werde ich heute das thema
zucker ansprechen also zucker in unseren
lebensmitteln
und am ende des videos habe ich noch
eine bitte an euch und brauche eure
hilfe
aber dazu komme ich erst später in
meinem video und möchte euch jetzt gerne
eben etwas über den zucker sagen
und zwar habe ich mich dazu entschlossen
über das thema zucker zu sprechen
noch vor einigen jahren hätte
wahrscheinlich keiner gedacht dass das
thema zucker überhaupt zum thema werden
kann weil es früher einfach so war also
noch vor fünf generationen war es so
dass die menschen etwa drei kilo zucker
pro jahr zu sich genommen haben und
heute liegt der verbrauch in deutschland
alleine schon bei 34 kilo pro mensch pro
jahr also dass ich echt die elffacher
menge eigentlich unglaublich dass sich
in den wenigen jahren ebenso viel
verändert hat und es hängt eben damit
zusammen dass die menschen heute einfach
nicht mehr selbst kochen sie bauen ihre
pflanzen und gemüse ihr obst nicht mehr
selbst an und die tiere züchten sie
nicht mehr selbst also alles wird immer
so von der industrie vorgegeben
es gibt viele fertigprodukte wir kochen
nicht mehr selber wir ernähren uns nur
noch von fertigen produkten und das ist
einfach der grund warum wir auch so viel
zucker zu uns nehmen weil in all den
fertigen produkten steckt einfach so
viel zucker drin
und dieser zucker ist wirklich versteckt
war weiß gar nicht wo überall da zucker
mit drin steckt wenn man nicht auf die
zutatenliste schaut und ich habe mich
heute einfach mal ein paar produkte
ausgesucht auch ein paar bekannte
produkte eben und möchte euch da jetzt
zeigen wie viel zucker da drinsteckt und
ich glaube oder was heißt ich glaube ich
weiß sogar dass er wahrscheinlich
wirklich ziemlich schockiert sein werdet
das war ich auch weil ich zwar wusste
dass zucker drin steckt aber nicht in
welchem ausmaß bild möchte ich mal mein
erstes produkt vorstellen und zwar habe
ich hier eine flasche tomatenketchup
dass sich
von heinz aber ist eigentlich bei jeder
anderen marke genauso diese flasche
beinhaltet 450 milliliter also 510 gramm
tomatenketchup und beide marken ketchup
denkmal eben auch toll da sind tomaten
drin und kann ein bisschen die
kommissare eindecken und allein in
dieser flasche ist so viel zucker drin
das heißt in dieser kleinen flasche mit
450 milliliter oder 510 gramm sind etwa
100 gramm zucker drin
das heißt ein viertel der flasche können
wir euch so bisher rechnen
das ist nur purer zucker und der rest
ist tomate gewürz und noch ein paar
andere stoffe
das heißt wenn ihr tomatenketchup ist
und euch etwa so einen klecks
tomatenketchup auf den teller gibt
könnte das durch vier teilen und ein
viertel davon ist eben pure zucker sind
nicht wie mein zweites produkt kennt ihr
wahrscheinlich alle hatten wir auch
schon mal angesprochen
das ist die milch schnitte und zwar ist
es ja so ein typisches beispiel einer
mogelpackung
es wird suggeriert dass man was gesundes
ist ja frische vollmilch und honig honig
ist auch gesund und allein in dieser
kleinen milchschnitte stecken drei
würfel zucker drin
die milch schnitte mit 28 gramm und ich
habe acht gramm zucker drin
ziemlich viel und ich hab euch ja schon
mal in einem video gezeigt wie man die
menschen selbst macht und da könnte ja
selbst bestimmen wie viel zucker ihr
haben wollt und das video verlinkt ich
euch hier und natürlich unten in meiner
infobox und da können da gerne mal
nachschauen und eben die milch-schnitte
etwas zucker reduziert herstellen
mein drittes produkt ist die schokolade
allein in dieser einen tafel alpenmilch
schokolade wird 100 gramm stecken 220
stück würfelzucker drin
das heißt ich kann eigentlich pröbchen
ein stück würfelzucker drauflegen und
erst pro weibchen und pro kleines
stückchen einwirken zu können
beim nächsten produkt könnt ihr euch
wahrscheinlich schon denken dass es viel
zucker enthält und zwar habe ich hier
eine colaflasche das war keine originale
aber da ist ja der zuckergehalt immer
gleich in dieser einen 1,5 liter flasche
stecken 60 würfel zucker drin
das sind etwa 180 gramm so sieht es
relativ wenig aus also könnte man meinen
dass sie da gar nicht so viel aus aber
was ich das so anschaut 60 würfelzucker
in dieser einen flasche ich meinen
manche menschen trinken ja wirklich eine
flasche komplett über den tag verteilt
dann habt ihr diese ganze zuckermenge zu
euch genommen
und manche menschen trinken das zum
beispiel an einem abend im kino um euch
das ganze nochmal etwas besser zu
verdeutlichen habe ich hier ein glas das
fast 200 milliliter also ein ganz
normales trinkglas und jeder kennt es ja
also ihr trinkt kaffee oder tee und
manche trinken das schwarz manche
trinken das aber mit 1 oder 2 zucker und
wenn ihnen ein glas cola trinkt ist es
so als würdet ihr in eurem tee oder in
euren café 9 würfel zucker stecken
und mal ganz ehrlich das könnte ja mal
ausprobieren der neuen würfelzucker
reingeben wie süß das dann wirklich ist
und wenn ich überlegt so an dem abend
wenn man eine party gefeiert wird oder
man essen geht da trinke ich auch mal
gerne ein glas cola aber wenn ich das
sehe ein würfelzucker kriege ich das
schon gesehen und nun zu meinem letzten
produkt um welches es heute auch geht
und zwar der beliebteste aufstrich der
deutschen und heller
ich habe jetzt hier ein glas mit 800
gramm
und ich war ehrlich gesagt sei
schockiert darüber wie viel zucker da
drinsteckt ich wusste dass mancher
nachhaltig ist und das ist auch
zuckerhaltig ist aber das ist wirklich
so extrem ist zeige ich euch jetzt mal
und danach werden wir natürlich auch
unseren hotels selbst machen und werden
gucken dass wir den zucker- und
fettgehalt etwas geringer halten und
zwar habe ich hier unser ganz normales
hotel la klaas und jetzt werdet ihr
wahrscheinlich erschreckend wie viel
zucker da drinsteckt
soviel ich habe jetzt hier ein ein liter
glas genommen von nutella einfach damit
man das eben zeigen kann wie viel eben
100 gramm steckt und dann ist es eben
einfacher das in einem liter oder in
einem kilo abzufüllen und ich konnte
anfangs gar nicht glauben ich habe es
zweimal abgewogen weil ich gedacht das
kann doch nicht sein dass noch nicht
hier bis hier oben voll sein mit zucker
aber in nutella sind sage und schreibe
55 gramm zucker pro 100 gramm drin das
heißt in meinem kilo nutella habe ich
550 gramm zucker und um das ganze in
würfel zucker zu zeigen
ich habe 183 würfelzucker in diesem
einen glas und das ist ja noch nicht
alles
ich habe in diesem einen glas nutella
sage und schreibe 300 gramm fett ich
habe das jetzt als öl hier abgefüllt um
eben zu zeigen dass das reines fett ist
also butter zu machen hätte ich jetzt
nicht nehmen können weil ja in butter
auch wasser drin steckt aber ihr habt
wirklich 300 gramm fett in diesem einen
glas und da frag ich mich ganz ehrlich
wo passt da noch irgendwie die
schokolade reihen die haselnüsse und
alles was so gesund sein soll schon
ziemlich erschreckend und bei der
kinderschokolade ist es genauso wie beim
nutella
also da ist auch 55 gramm zucker pro 100
gramm drin und auch genauso viel fett
und wir kommen uns natürlich auch gerne
wie essen gern kinderschokolade wir
essen auch janne teller ich liebe
nutella
ich finde es gibt auch keinen besseren
nuss nougat aufstrich als nutella aber
ich finde man sollte eben behutsam damit
umgehen und was ich ihm dabei findet ist
das zum beispiel auf der kinder
schokolade eben ein kind mit darauf
abgebildet ist dass es überhaupt
kinderschokolade heißt oder dass eine
deutsche fußball nationalmannschaft für
nutella wird weil es einfach nicht
gesund ist und bei den produkten ist es
einfach so dass in süßigkeiten also ein
nutella ist kein brotaufstrich den mal
jeden tag seinem kind zu essen geben
sollte bei uns gibt's nur teller nur am
wochenende unter der woche wird müsli
gegessen oder eben frisches obst gemüse
etwas käse aber nutella es wirklich so
war es das solltet ihr seiten essen
natürlich darf das essen aber es gehört
eben zu den süßigkeiten und nicht zum
frühstück und gerade bei kindern oder
auch erwachsenen ist es so dass man zwar
süßigkeiten essen darf soll man ja auch
zucker braucht ja auch der körper aber
eben nur eine portion am tag und wenn
ich überlege ich es morgens ein
nutellabrot dann habe ich eigentlich
schon meine portion an süßigkeiten und
meinen bedarf gedeckt es ist nämlich so
dass man das anhand seiner hand einfach
ab messen kann und ein kind hat ja
wirklich mini händler ich meine dass
amira ist nicht da aber sie sollte nur
so viel süßigkeiten essen wie auch in
ihre kleine hand passt also in die
handfläche und das könnt ihr euch so als
richtlinie neben eben für eure
süßigkeiten und dann könnte er wirklich
einmal am tag naschen oder euch das in
portionen aufteilen
und dann macht auch wirklich nix wenn
man diese produkte kauft und die region
ist jetzt möchte ich aber zu meinem bett
kommen und euch zeigen wie ich meinen
teil auch selbst machen und zwar ist es
ein ganz einfaches rezept noch ein sehr
schnelles rezept und ich habe mir da
auch die erweiterte zusammengerechnet
und kann euch dann nach dem rezept mal
sagen wie viel fett wie viel zucker das
ganze hat und wie sich die kalorien eben
von meinem selbstgemacht nutella zudem
gekauften nutella unterscheiden aber
dazu zeige ich will jetzt einfach mal
die zutaten ihr braucht 80 gramm zucker
60 gramm haselnüsse 100 gramm schokolade
ich habe jetzt hier zahlt
bitterschokolade 70 gramm butter und 100
gramm milch da habe ich jetzt die milch
mit 1,5 prozent fett
ich habe jetzt ganze havel rissen
natürlich könnt ihr aber auch gemahlene
haselnüsse nehmen dann erspart ihr euch
eben das feine malen aber ich nehme
gerne ganze haselnüsse einfach weil ich
das aroma viel besser findet und ich
habe jetzt auch noch einen kleinen tick
und zwar weil ich meine haselnüsse
gleich noch etwas anrösten um dieses
muster aroma eben besser hervorzuheben
denn müssen schmecken wenn sie gerüstet
sind viel viel besser weil sie ihr aroma
entfalten können
ich verwende in meiner rezept
bitterschokolade weil da die schokolade
eben weniger zucker enthält und mehr
kakaoanteil dh die schokolade ist
weniger zooms und ist mehr schokolade
und ich verwende die 15 prozentige milch
weil sie eben fettärmer ist als die 35
und da sparen wir eben auch an fett und
mit diesen zutaten werden zeigen wie ich
meine mutter aller hersteller
ich gebe jetzt die haselnüsse in meiner
trockenen pfanne und weiß jetzt darin
etwas anrösten und das mache ich ohne
fett und da schenkt ihr einfach immer
mal wieder die pfanne und ihr werdet
dann merken dass das so langsam anfängt
zu knistern und es riecht dann auch so
wie auf dem weihnachtsmarkt und dann
müsste auch aufpassen dass ihr die hände
sind nicht verbrennen lässt
und dann seht ihr auch dass die nüsse
ihre schale verlieren und das ist auch
gut so die nehmen wir dann nämlich
gleich weg und dann könnt ihr den herd
ausschalten und die müsse aus der pfanne
herausnehmen
ich werde die nüsse jetzt im thermomix
zerkleinern natürlich könnte da jeden
anderen mixa dafür verwenden und dafür
nehme ich sie eben jetzt hier heraus
ohne schale und gibt es hier in den mix
topf
jetzt klein mal und so sehen sie dann
bei mir aus dann gebe ich die milch in
einen kleinen topf und gibt da auch den
zucker mit dazu damit sich da eben in
der milch auflösen kann
das ganze lasse ich jetzt einmal
aufkochen dann schalte ich den herd
runter aufpassen dass überkocht und gebt
dann die butter mit dazu damit die sich
jetzt auch auflösen kann
das ganze soll es auch gar nicht mehr
kochen sondern das soll sich jetzt
einfach kurz schön auflösen und jetzt
gebe ich hier die schokolade mit rein
und lass die schönen langsam dorthin
auflösen
und wenn ihr merkt dass sie die
schokolade kommt
aufgelöst hat könnt ihr jetzt auch die
haselnüsse mit dazu geben
und im prinzip ist es so dann auch schon
fertig ich werde das ganze jetzt in ein
schraubglas umfüllen
das muss er jetzt erstmal noch abkühlen
damit die konsistenz eben festwirt und
so wird wie bei dem original nutella das
will ich einfach in so ein leeres
marmeladenglas rein und es hat auch noch
richtig coole geschenkidee also das
selbst gemacht ist nutella einfach mal
verschenken
ihr müsst aber bedenken dass dieses
nutella eben nicht so lange haltbar ist
wie das originale weil einfach keine
konservierungsstoffe enthalten sind im
kühlschrank würde ich das so bis
eineinhalb wochen lager anleger nicht
wegen der frischen milch und wegen der
mutter und ihr seht das ist etwa so eine
menge das sind 420 gramm insgesamt und
es sieht natürlich auch ganz süß aus
wenn ihr kleine gläschen nehmt und eben
kleine verpackungen und verschenkt und
dann gibt es da einfach den deckel drauf
und wie gesagt so etwa eineinhalb wochen
würde ich es lagern länger nicht ich
denke man kann das auch ganz gut
einfrieren und dann wieder aufbauen und
so habt ihr euer eigenes selbst gemacht
dass nutella in den kühlschrank stellen
und wertz morgen früh daneben rausholen
und probieren und euch natürlich auch
zeigen
am nächsten tag ist die konsistenz des
selbstgemachten mit lastern so und ihr
seht es ist richtig schön streichfähig
ganz wichtig ist das sind es immer
verschlossen im kühlschrank aufbewahrt
so etwa bis eineinhalb wochen
so lange ist es haltbar bei
zimmertemperatur wird es nämlich
schneller verderben
aber ich möchte euch jetzt noch mal
sagen was in diesem hotel jetzt drin
steckt und wie viel kalorien wir sparen
im gegensatz zu dem original nutella wie
viel fett und zucker wir sparen eben
original nutella haben wir 547 kalorien
pro 100 gramm und in unserem
selbstgemachten nutella haben wir 435
kalorien also deutlich weniger im
original produkt haben wir 56,8
kohlenhydrate also zucker und dem
nachgemachten haben wir nur 31 gramm pro
100 g
im original nutella haben wir 31
das haben wir auch im nachgemachten
notar und eiweiß haben wir im original
nutella 6,6 gramm und bei unserem 5,2
kamen liebsten hotels sagen schaut mal
wie kies und selbstgemachtes ist aber
auch das selbstgemachte nutella ist
natürlich nicht gesund das zählt auch zu
den süßigkeiten und enthält natürlich
auch viel fett und viel zucker aber im
vergleich zum original eben deutlich
weniger wobei beides sehr gut schmeckt
das originalmodell an natürlich auch
eines meiner favoriten dieses
nachgemachte schmeckt einfach anders und
es müsste einfach auf jeden fall mal
probieren vielleicht probierte auch mal
die hälfte der menge
das riecht einfach viel besser also
gerade gerösteten haselnüssen es
schmeckt mehr nach schokolade und mehr
nach haselnuss als das original
vergleichbar sind sie jetzt meiner
meinung nach nicht ganz besonders weil
einfach das original nutella auch andere
aromen drin hat also das hat ja auch
wirklich oben mit drin
das haben wir nicht wir haben jetzt hier
natürliche aroma aus unserem haselnüssen
und eben aus unserer schokolade und auf
jeden fall werde ich euch auch die
nährwertangaben noch auf meinem blog
eben zum rezept dazu schreiben und euch
eben die ganze auflistung durch eben
mündlich gesagt habe auch schriftlich
schreiben
jetzt komme ich zu meiner ganz großen
bitte und möchte jetzt hier mit das
rezept beenden
und zwar ist es bei mir so dass ich ja
in letzter zeit zwar sei wenig zeit
hatte aufgrund meiner prüfungen da steht
übrigens eine noch bevor und wenn ich
dir geschafft habe bin ich unendlich
prüfungs frei und habe wieder mehr zeit
kann bei videos drehen und einfach auch
dieser leidenschaft noch mehr nachgehen
und es war es auch so dass mich in
dieser zeit auch einige fernsehsender
angeschrieben haben unter anderem zum
beispiel ein türkischer sender da gerne
eine lifestyle sendung mit mir und
meiner freundin eco von ex beatle
ausmachen würde
und zwar soll da die epro so ein
bisschen schminken und kosmetik tipps
geben und ich eben kochen und backen und
für die bau- und freude sorgen
da sind diego und ich gemeinsam auch
noch dran und mit der epo wird auch noch
ein
videos zusammen geben und wenn die epo
von euch nicht kennt der geht mal auf
große kino steht ihr auch einen großen
youtube kanal und ein anderer sender
damit an geschrieben hat ist ein
deutscher sender
da darf ich den namen leider noch nicht
nennen und die möchten dann eine back
sendung machen und habe mich gefragt ob
ich nicht lust dazu hätte eben da die
back protagonistin zu sein und praktisch
diese sendung zu machen als moderatorin
und eben mit meinen backrezepte nich
könnte dann leute einladen und ebenso
eine ganz normale wachsen und im
fernsehen haben und das ganze stelle ich
mir ziemlich cool vor weil ich mir
gedacht habe ich habe dann meine wachsen
und nach der bucks sendung können wir
dann online auf diesem auf dieser
plattform eben auch noch miteinander
chatten und fragen austauschen und
beantworten so wie es eben jetzt auch
unter meinen youtube-videos stattfindet
da bekomme ich ja auch zahlreiche fragen
von euch und beantwortest ihr euch gerne
ob sie kurz oder lang sind
da versuche ich wirklich auf jede frage
eine antwort zu finden und ich soll mich
jetzt bei dem sender vorstellen und
einfach mal ein paar gründe nennen
weshalb ich die richtige person wäre für
eine eigene box sendung und diese
aufgabe würde ich ganz gern an euch
weitergeben weil er mich ja auch kennen
dich bekommen ja auch wirklich viel
positives feedback von euch viel
unterstützung und freue mich da auch
wirklich jedes mal drüber und jetzt
würde ich euch darum bitten auch wenn
ihr zum beispiel noch nie den kommentar
bei mir geschrieben habe gerade euch
würde ich jetzt darum bitten mir mal
einen kommentar zu schreiben weshalb ihr
glaubt dass ich die richtige person für
eine eigene box sendung im fernsehen bin
und dazu brauche ich jetzt ein paar
anregungen ein paar argumente von euch
für den sender die den sender eben
darüber davon überzeugen warum ich
eventuell der richtige bin die eben eine
eigene box sendung im fernsehen haben
sollte da spreche ich dich an und fragt
sich weshalb soll ich eine
fernsehsendung eine box sendung im
fernsehen bekommen weiter man mich
eventuell jede woche zieht
ich freue mich schon auf eure
zahlreichen kommentare als ihr das
nutella rezept nach machen wollt geht
natürlich auch meinen blog auf
www.starbett.de
ich freue mich wirklich schon wahnsinnig
darauf eure kommentare zu lesen und
bitte euch darum wirklich auch einen
kommentar dazu lassen und am sonntag 10
wir uns wieder mit einem neuen rezept
von salis classics und ich werde jetzt
auch nach und nach immer meine
versprechen einlösen und die ganzen
videos auch drehen die ich eben
vorgeschlagen hatte auch meine torten
videos natürlich werden auch uster
videos kommen und natürlich auch ganz
viele pikante rezepte wenn euch das
video gefallen hat dann gebt mir gern
eine bewertung lassen kommentar da und
teilt das video mit euren freunden und
jetzt wünsche ich euch noch einen ganz
schönen tag und ich komme bald mit ganz
vielen neuen informationen